-So -- All right. So,
Britney Spears, who we all know,
and "Mary Had a Little Lamb."
-All right.
-Which is pretty -- Yeah.
So, Roots, can you give a little
music here for Britney Spears?
♫♫
-[ As Britney Spears ]
♫ Mar... ♫
[ Laughter ]
♫ ...ry had ♫
♫ A ♫
♫ Little lamb ♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
♫♫
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
-That´s enough.
♫♫
[ Blabbering indistinctly ]
That´s truly great.
Alright, now it´s my turn.
[ Both laugh ]
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
"Cheerleader."
-"Cheerleader."
-Uh, I know -- Aaron --
Oh, oh, yeah, OMI,
oh, okay, yeah.
Aaron Neville doing
"Cheerleader" by OMI. Okay.
-♫ Cheerleader ♫
♫♫
-[ As Aaron Neville ]
♫ Oh, think I found myself ♫
♫ A cheerleader ♫
♫ She´s always right there ♫
♫ When I need her, oh ♫
♫ Oh, I, I, I, I ♫
♫ A cheerleader ♫
[ Babbling indistinctly ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Murmuring ] ♫ Cheerleader ♫
Thank you very much. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don´t know. I love that song,
"Cheerleader." Okay, good.
Alright, Ariana, you´re up.
You´re up, you´re up.
-Alright. 6, 7, 8.
[ Laughter ]
-Christina Aguilera doing
"The Wheels on the Bus."
-Okay.
-Christina Aguilera doing
"The Wheels on the Bus."
Roots --
♫♫
-[ Chuckles ]
-[ As Christina ]
♫ The ♫
[ Vocalizing ]
♫♫
♫ The wheels ♫
♫ On the bus go ♫
♫ They go round and around
and, ooh, oh ♫
♫ They go ♫
[ Vocalizing ]
♫ Round ♫
♫ They go round
and around, hey ♫
♫ Wheels on the bus ♫
♫ They go ♫
♫ Round, round ♫
[ Vocalizing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♫ They go ♫
[ Vocalizing ]
♫♫
♫ Round ♫
[ Vocalizing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ha.
♫ Round ♫
♫ Ooh ♫ Ha.
-[ Laughing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Adding the "Ha."
-Ha.
-Oh, my --
-That makes it, the "Ha."
-We should just
stop the show there.
I don´t know
how we can continue.
That is unbelievable.
-Thanks.
-Wow, I want that recording.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, I don´t even know why
I´m gonna continue to play,
but here we go.
Sting.
-Sting.
-"Can´t Feel My Face."
-Oh, it´s so good.
That´s so good. That´s perfect.
-[ Clears throat ]
♫♫
♫ Hey ♫
Alright.
♫♫
Okay, thank you.
[ As Sting ] ♫ I can´t feel
my face when I´m with you ♫
♫ But I love it ♫
♫ Oh, I can´t feel my face
when I´m with you ♫
♫ But I love it ♫
♫ But I love it, but
I love it, yeah ♫
♫♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was nice. Great.
Thank you. Alright.
-That was perfect.
-No. Please.
Alright, now it´s your turn.
It´s on you.
-Okay.
I love this game.
-Me, too.
Celine!
-Oh, God.
-It´s a double
"Can´t Feel My Face."
-It´s a "Can´t Feel
My Face"-off.
-It´s a "Can´t
Feel My Face"-off.
Roots, do it --
So don´t do the same thing.
You got to do a higher key
´cause --
-Celine would take it up.
-Celine would want to -- Yeah.
-She would modulate.
♫♫
[ Vocalizes ] Is that right?
[ Vocalizing ]
Is that right?
♫♫
6.
[ As Celine ] ♫ I can´t feel
my face when I´m with you ♫
♫ But I love it ♫
So much!
So do you!
♫ I can´t feel my face
when I´m with you, yeah ♫
♫ But I love it ♫
Come on!
Shall we go for it?
♫ I can´t feel my face
when I´m with you ♫
-[ As Sting ] ♫ I can´t feel
my face with you ♫
-♫ But I love it ♫
-♫ Oh, I love it ♫
[ Babbling indistinctly ]
-♫ I can´t feel my face
when I´m with you ♫
-♫ I can´t feel
my face with you ♫
-♫ But, oh ♫
-♫ But I ♫ [Babbles]
[ Both vocalizing ]
♫♫
-♫ But I love it ♫
-♫ But I love what you do ♫
-♫ But I love it, yeah ♫
-Ariana Grande!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Wheel of Musical Impressions"!
You´re the greatest.
Now, Ariana, you´re obviously
a great singer,
and you can also sing
in so many different styles.
So with that in mind, it´s time
for a "Musical Genre Challenge."
Here we go.
-♫ Musical genre challenge ♫
-All right, now here´s how
it works, okay?
We´re gonna take turns hitting
this button here,
which activates
the Random Genre Generator.
Or Random Jenre Jenerator.
[ Laughter ]
It will land on
one random song title
and one random musical genre.
Whoever´s turn it is has to sing
that song in that style.
-Okay.
-All right?
I will start us off.
Here we go. You ready?
One, two, three.
"Shape of You."
Ska.
[ Laughter ]
I kind of know --
I know "Shape of You."
I know a little ska.
How fast is ska?
♫♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
♫ I´m in love
with the shape of you ♫
♫ Push and pull
like a magnet too ♫
♫ My heart is falling too ♫
♫ I´m in love with your body ♫
♫ Oh, I, oh, I, oh, I, oh, I ♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a little -- I don´t
know what I was doing there.
All right.
I´ll let you go ahead.
Ariana, it´s your turn.
Go ahead.
-Okay.
-All right.
It is "Humble."
-Goth rock.
Like, goth rock -- like 2003
Evanescence goth rock?
-Yeah.
What does that sound like, yeah?
-Like, hot topic shopping goth?
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, how does that sound?
Yeah.
-♫ Oh ♫
♫ Right stroke put Lil baby
in a spiral ♫
♫ Soprano C, we like to keep it
on a high note ♫
♫ It´s levels to it ♫
♫ You and I know, bitch,
sit down ♫
♫ Be humble ♫
♫ Sit down ♫
♫ Oh, sit down ♫
♫ Be humble ♫
♫ Sit down ♫
♫ Oh, sit down ♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?! Stop it.
-♫ Sit down ♫
-Wow. Wow!
That´s exactly what it was.
All right.
I don´t know why,
but I´m going again.
Okay. Here we go.
That was fantastic.
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah," the Usher song. "Yeah."
Yeah. Boop boop.
In a country jam?
[ Laughter ]
♫♫
♫ I was up in the club
with my homies trying to ♫
No. Stop, stop.
Can we do like --
[ Laughter ]
You know what? Maybe like a --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can we do like a Johnny Cash --
I feel like a Johnny Cash, like
a slower, like a recent,
like a later Johnny Cash.
Like a Rick Rubin/Johnny Cash,
like "Hurt."
Like really slow.
♫♫
Yeah, yeah, okay. Yeah.
All right, yeah. Yeah, okay.
Here we go.
♫♫
♫ I was up in the club
with my homies ♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
♫ Trying to get a little V.I. ♫
♫ Keep it down on the low key ♫
♫ And I´m like, yeah ♫
♫ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
That´s the best I could do.
That´s the best I can do. Sorry.
All right.
-That was so good. Okay.
-Ariana, take us home.
-"God´s Plan."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"God´s plan."
-´90s diva.
So, like, poppy.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-"God´s plan," Drake. ´90s diva.
♫♫
-[ Vocalizes ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♫ I hold back sometimes ♫
♫ I don´t, yeah, yeah ♫
♫ I feel good sometimes ♫
♫ I finessed down Weston Road ♫
♫ Yeah, yeah, oh, oh ♫
♫ Might go down a G.O.D. ♫
♫ Yeah, yeah ♫
♫ God´s plan, yeah ♫
♫ God´s plan ♫
♫ God´s plan, yay ♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
That is it for
Musical Genre Challenge.
Ariana Grande!
-Jimmy Fallon!
-Come on!
Hi, guys, I´m here with the one
and only Ariana Grande.
And we´re gonna do something
really fun here.
In the next room are some
of Ariana´s biggest fans,
and they´re going to do a cover
of one of Ariana´s songs,
thinking that it´s a fan video
for Ariana to show to her.
What they don´t know is that,
she´s actually right next
to them, listening to them live.
And we´re going to surprise them
and then, say hi to them.
-Yeah.
-Here we go.
You ready to do this?
-We´re gonna do it now.
One, two, three.
-Yep.
-♫ I was a liar ♫
♫ I gave into the fire ♫
♫ I know I should´ve fought it ♫
♫ At least I´m being honest ♫
-♫ Feel like a failure ♫
♫ ´Cause I know
that I failed you ♫
♫ Should´ve done you better ♫
♫ ´Cause you don´t want a liar ♫
-♫ And I know
and I know and I know ♫
♫ She gives you everything but
boy, I couldn´t give it to you ♫
-♫ And I know
and I know and I know ♫
♫ That you got everything but
I got nothing here without you ♫
-♫ So one last time ♫
♫ I need to be the one ♫
♫ Who takes you home ♫
♫ One more time ♫
♫ I need to be ♫
-You sound great!
-Oh, oh!
Oh, my God!
You´re real. You´re real.
You´re really real.
-Yes, you´re so cute.
-Oh, my God.
Jimmy, hi!
Oh, my God!
-♫ One last time ♫
♫ I need to be the one ♫
♫ Who takes you home ♫
♫ One more ♫
-Sorry, just do one more.
-What?
-We´ll just do one more take
and then --
Ariana, what do you think?
-I thought it was really good.
-What?!
-♫ One last time ♫
♫ I need to be the one ♫
♫ Who takes you home ♫
♫ One more time ♫
♫ I promise to ♫
Oh, my God!
Stop!
-Hi, surprise.
That was great.
And I loved your alt melodies.
-Yes, you did it all --
-You made a different choice.
I was like, "Oh, hell yeah."
-♫ Know I should´ve fought it ♫
♫ At least I´m being honest ♫
♫ Yeah ♫
[ Strumming guitar out of tune ]
♫ ´Cause I don´t want
to be without you ♫
-That was amazing.
-Hi.
-Hi!
Oh, my God.
-Hi.
-Oh, my God.
Ariana, I have been a fan
of you, since "Yours Truly."
-Oh, my gosh.
-You´ve been my inspiration
my whole life.
-Thank you.
-How long have you --
How long have you been of mine?
-For, like, nine years.
-Of mine.
-Oh, of you?
-Yeah.
-Well, um --
Thank you very much.
-Take care. Yeah.
Just get some DVDs.
You can start watching the show.
-I love you.
[ Laughter ]
Bye. Thank you.
-11:30, it´s on NBC.
-I will watch it.
-Yeah? All right, cool.
-♫ And I know
and I know and I know ♫
♫ That you´ve got everything but
I got nothing here without ♫
Oh, my God!
Oh, my God.
Hi.
-Sorry, I messed up.
-Yeah.
-It´s okay, we got you.
-You messed up a little bit.
-Don´t worry, we´ll help.
-No.
-Hey.
-Are you ser--
-Hi!
I love this. It´s like
"No Tears Left to Cry."
-Oh, God.
-I love your writing.
Yeah. Oh, my God.
You look so good.
-I try, but I feel
like Swiss cheese.
-No!
-[ Laughing ] My gosh.
-♫ Should´ve done you better ♫
♫ ´Cause you don´t want a liar ♫
♫ And I know
and I know and I know ♫
♫ She gives you everything but
boy I couldn´t give it to you ♫
-I think we we got that take.
Sorry.
-It was good.
That was great.
-Oh, my God.
-It was perfect!
It was fine. It was fine.
It was great.
You sound great.
-Ahh!
Oh, my God!
-You sound great.
-♫ One last time ♫
-♫ I was a liar ♫
♫ I gave into the fire ♫
♫ I know I should´ve fought it ♫
♫ At least I´m being honest ♫
♫ So one last time ♫
♫ I need to be the one ♫
♫ Who takes you home ♫
♫ One more ♫
-You sound beautiful.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Cutie.
You sound so great.
I´m so happy to meet you.
You sound beautiful.
-I love you so much.
-I love you, too.
-Me and The Roots got Ariana
Grande to come sing her hit song
"No Tears Left to Cry."
Now, keep in mind that every
sound you´re about to hear
was made by a video game system.
Please enjoy this.
-Hooray!
[ Instruments playing ]
♫♫
-♫ Right now,
I´m in a state of mind ♫
♫ I wanna be in
like all the time ♫
♫ Ain´t got no tears
left to cry ♫
♫ So I´m pickin´ it up,
pickin´ it up ♫
♫ Lovin´, I´m livin´,
I´m pickin´ it up ♫
♫ Pickin´ it up, pickin´ it up ♫
♫ I´m lovin´, I´m livin´, I´m ♫
♫ Oh, yeah, I´m pickin´ it up ♫
♫ Lovin´, I´m livin´,
so we turnin´ up ♫
♫ Yeah, we turnin´ it up ♫
♫♫
♫ Ain´t got no tears
in my body ♫
♫ I ran out,
but, boy, I like it ♫
♫ I like it, I like it ♫
♫ Don´t matter how,
what, where, who tries it ♫
♫ We´re out here vibin´ ♫
♫ We vibin´, we vibin´ ♫
-♫ Comin´ out ♫
-♫ Even when it´s rainin´ down ♫
-♫ Can´t stop now ♫
-♫ Can´t stop,
so shut your mouth ♫
-♫ Shut your mouth ♫
-♫ And if you don´t know,
then now you know it, babe ♫
♫ Know it, babe, yeah ♫
♫ Right now,
I´m in a state of mind ♫
♫ I wanna be in
like all the time ♫
♫ Ain´t got no tears
left to cry, so ♫
-♫ I´m pickin´ it up,
pickin´ it up ♫
-♫ Oh, yeah ♫
-♫ I´m lovin´, I´m livin´,
I´m pickin´ it up ♫
-♫ Oh, I just want you
to come with me ♫
♫ We on another mentality ♫
♫ Ain´t got no tears
left to cry ♫
♫ So I´m pickin´ ♫
-♫ Pickin´ it up ♫
-♫ Oh, yeah, babe ♫
-♫ I´m lovin´, I´m livin´,
I´m pickin´ it up ♫
-♫ I´m pickin´ it up,
pickin´ it up ♫
♫ Lovin´, I´m livin´,
so we turnin´ up ♫
♫ Yeah, we turnin´ it up ♫
-Turnin´ it up.
-♫ They point out
the colors in you ♫
♫ I see ´em, too,
and, boy, I like ´em ♫
♫ I like ´em, I like ´em ♫
♫ We way too fly
to partake in all this hate ♫
♫ We out here vibin´ ♫
♫ We vibin´, we vibin´ ♫
-♫ Comin´ out ♫
-♫ Even when it´s rainin´ down ♫
-♫ Can´t stop now ♫
-♫ Can´t stop,
so shut your mouth ♫
-♫ Shut your mouth ♫
-♫ And if you don´t know,
then now you know it, babe ♫
♫ Know it, babe, yeah ♫
♫ Right now,
I´m in a state of mind ♫
♫ I wanna be in
like all the time ♫
♫ Ain´t got no tears
left to cry ♫
♫ So I´m pickin´ ♫
-♫ I´m pickin´ it up ♫
-♫ Oh, yeah ♫
-♫ I´m lovin´, I´m livin´,
I´m pickin´ it up ♫
-♫ Oh, I just want you
to come with me ♫
♫ We on another mentality ♫
♫ Ain´t got no tears
left to cry, to cry, so ♫
-♫ So I´m pickin´ it up ♫
♫ I´m pickin´ it up ♫
-♫ Oh, yeah ♫
-♫ I´m lovin´, I´m livin´,
I´m pickin´ it up ♫
-♫ I´m pickin´ it up,
pickin´ it up ♫
♫ Lovin´, I´m livin´,
so we turnin´ up ♫
♫ Yeah, we turnin´ it up ♫
[ Fingers snap,
cheers and applause ]
-Here´s how the game works.
You draw a question
from the Best Friends Box.
Then the other person guesses
how they think
you would answer that question.
We´ll see how many
we can get right.
Ariana, I want you to draw
the first question.
-Okay.
Do I --
-Yeah, you can --
Yes, you ask the question,
-I don´t want to -- Okay.
"If I could be any animal,
what animal would I be?"
Oh, so this is you guessing
what I would --
If I could be any animal,
which one would I be?
And I write the real answer.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I write the real answer, too.
But I know you, so...
Any animal,
what animal would you be?
Okay, show your answer
to that camera,
and I won´t look.
-Okay.
-Okay. Did you show it?
[ Audience "oh"s ]
That sounds like the audience
was surprised.
Okay.
My answer is...
a kitty cat.
-Oh, that´s a good one.
-A seahorse? The hell you --
Hell you talking about?
-I don´t know.
-Seahorse?
-I like them.
-You wear like bunny ears
and cat ears all the time.
-You´re right.
-Like a kitty cat.
-Okay. Alright. You get you get
that one anyway.
-A seahorse? I was close.
-But you can´t wear
like seahorse ears.
Like, what are those? Like --
-No, but I wouldn´t say
you got the drift, but I mean,
you kind of hinted
that you like --
-I know. Sorry, man.
-I don´t know.
-I really misled you.
I apologize.
-No, here we go. We´re good.
We´re good. Ready?
-Okay.
-What food do I hate the most?
-Oh, I don´t know.
-I´m putting
the vibes out there.
Barf, just writing it.
I´m going to show my answer.
Don´t look.
Oh, you didn´t write yet.
You just got it?
-Because I -- go ahead.
-You got my vibe?
Alright. You got my vibe now?
-I think maybe,
-Okay, this is great. Alright.
-Go ahead, you go.
-Don´t look. Ready?
Blurf!
Blurf.
-I look -- I tried to look,
but I´m blind, so it doesn´t --
I can´t see.
-No, it´s --
Let´s see what your answer was.
-What? Mustard?
Mustard is so delicious.
It´s yellow.
It´s got like spices in it.
It´s vinegary. Mayonnaise --
You know why I don´t like it.
It reminds me of pus.
-Yeah, I don´t like it, either.
[ Audience groaning ]
-Oh, stop.
Yeah, everyone loves it.
This is upsetting.
-I was close, though.
-You were very close.
-In the condiment family.
-You´re right.
-We´re there.
-Alright, ready? This is
the one we´re going to get.
I know it. You pick it.
-Oh, my turn.
-Yeah, here we go.
I´ll guess this one.
-Okay.
Man.
-Oh, this is a good one.
Who was my first
celebrity crush?
A little bit --
a little embarrassing.
You know, yeah.
To have to actually
write it down.
[ Laughing, stammering ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Both laugh ]
You show it to your --
Oh, maybe I´ll show mine first.
-Go ahead.
-Ready?
Don´t look.
Ariana, show yours.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Jim Carrey ]
Let me show you something.
[ Normal voice ] First celebrity
crush, Jim Carrey.
Very close. I was very close.
This is the one that counts.
Alright.
What is my most embarrassing
bad habit?
Why did you write it that fast?
Like, that all the other ones,
you really thought about it,
you know, and then this one --
Lookit, you´re writing
like three sentences.
Oh, my gosh.
Alright, I´m gonna
show mine first.
Should I show mine first?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-My most embarrassing
bad habit is...
I laugh too much.
-No, I like your laugh.
You´re good in that department.
This was the one --
[ Laughter ]
♫♫
-That´s right, ´cause
I´m your second crush!
I got you, girl!
Ariana Grande, everybody!